montrer que les maladies psychiques
n'altère en rien la sensibilité et
l'intelligence artistique tel est
l'objectif de l'association art
convergence al exposé à versailles les
oeuvres de huit de ces artistes
l'occasion de découvrir leur univers
originaux à l'image des fleurs mandala
des zoos inspiré de la culture pop
japonaise en les réalisant j'ai réussi à
retrouver une espèce de sérénité en fait
j'ai eu beaucoup de plaisir à les faire
et j'ai ressenti beaucoup de beaucoup
d'émotions positives allait faire en
fait leur cap si chic et peut-être même
un moteur à la création dans le sens où
les personnes handicapées aux handicapés
ont fléchi qu'ont souvent une
sensibilité exacerbée en fait et donc
qui est propice à la création autre
univers fantasmagorique celui de la
jeune laura n'a et de son minutieux
travail pour constituer cet univers
aquatique réalisé avec 90 % de matériaux
de récupération animaux marins real y
côtoie personnages imaginaires comme
cette sirène fabriqué à partir d'une
poupée japonaise unijambiste pour
réaliser leurs travaux pendant un an les
artistes de l'association a été
accompagnée par des artistes
professionnels
l'intérêt de l'association s'est aussi
de mettre en relation des des
collectivités locales avec des
structures de soins avec des artistes en
fait on a quand même un rôle de lien et
passeur au cirque en fait c'est enfin
c'est principalement ça notre notre
objectif jusqu'au 18 septembre les
oeuvres de ces huit artistes d'art
convergence seront confrontés à la vie
du public à la galerie de l'école des
beaux-arts une opportunité pour eux
d'exposer dans des conditions
professionnelles